tu as commencé le piano à 7 ont eu six
ou sept ans et a commencé à composer à
14 ans qui est aussi beatmakers que tu
te sois nous faire un petit truc à quoi
va nous faire un petit coucou un petit
chez soi c'est de la musique pas avec sa
bouche quoique 0 avec sa bouche ou evans
beatmaker cv car c'est pas ben ben ouais
c'est vrai qu'ils font plus car c'est
calme toi qui n'as tu pas de composer un
truc là ici on avait tout à fait vous
avec toi matériel ici et il ya une meuf
qui nous a laissé tomber qu'importait va
nous faire un truc ou pas non c'est toi
qui comporte tout et tuent tout c'est
toi qui fait tout je suis quasi sûr 9,9
instruits sur mon album
on est très contentes de voir tu vois
c'est un peu avec nous ça tu regarde
souvent l'émission ça dépend benjamin
castadi tu tues tu connais depuis tout
petit
[Applaudissements]
tu regardais love story avec l'autre là
commencent à s'inquiéter de la piscine
maintenant c'est kelly et elle était
très belle et reste toujours très belle
loana oui non je vous le dis oui de
leurs mots tu connaissais
bah oui ah ouais t'as vu dans mes joues
tu avais regardées moufia l'émission sur
les chiens sur nrj 12
non mesdames aussi tu vas connaissez
quand a été sur tf1
laon verna remonte y est j'ai regardé
vidéo gag
ah bah oui il est trop jeune à être
c'est vrai j'ai dit aux gars que tu
racontes toi et toi la vérité frères
sahraouis
tu as fait le tour du cadran à tête de
ma mère ça veut dire le gars même pas pu
regarder vos vidéos gags nord quand ça
s'est arrêté n'était pas content quand
ça sert oui allez nous parler des
tranferts
non mais c'est christian kelly csa kelly
vdev ni très belle égéries bella elle
répondait au nom de bella c'était
[Applaudissements]
rêvons astugue les bassins
chauffeur-livreur c'est un pote à moi et
je les mets dans l'émission du lait mais
lui en fait il est chauffeur livreur lui
du pôle voir le matin à rungis à la
croix par habitude il a avec des cages
où il forme des clémentines mon frère je
te le dis c'est pas une vanne du tout
soit elle ne la mérite pas vraiment les
chauffeurs-livreurs ben c'est vrai ce
bien sûr bon mamie tu là dedans voilà et
géraldine maillet c'est ben c'est
géraldine maillet malheur romancière à
succès réalisatrice ça va elle ça ferait
trop collé pas vu celle-ci absolument
était sur roland garros c'est un peu si
roland garros un peu sur plein de
projets avec moi vous avez vous êtes
vous est métamorphosé là bas touché les
fesses
il est comme ça il ya les autres face à
l'om on est en plein boom postérieurs
féminins savez ça passe et géraldine
maillet on n'arrive pas tous les jours
et enfin doc gynéco
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l intérêt que représente éléments drap
d'or à trucs de magie
non mais sans rire non mais un truc de
ouf ça va bien aujourd'hui il dort tout
en un ça va c'est quand il est réveillé
qu'on lui demande tu es bien l'ami sa
maman chérie qui est appelé hier soir
toi j'ai pensé à l'émission
d'aujourd'hui j'ai commencé à réviser
mes frères on a le conducteur on sait ce
que l'on aime jouer à 15h
nous commençons à l'abeille tu as déjà
travaillé sur l'émission en fait ta vie
c'est te foutent de ma gueule
si j'ai reçu l'album du frère je l'avais
reçu depuis hier je crois d'accord bah
oui oui c'est vrai qu'on peut écrire
autant sur des papiers parler aussi plus
dans l'émission vous décrivez parce que
j'espère qu'un jour je saurai ce qu'il
écrit mais je sais pas ou alors vous
avez vu comment c'est moi c'est un but
par roger galéré
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai galéré va rester à son scooter la
vidéo en plus il pleut d'ouf je suis
arrivée là y'avait même pas un quart
d'heure tu sais que tu es sabah vous
suivi ouais je te promets l'egée les
boîtes à galérer j'ai fait j'étais super
je suis arrivé de place clichy main
jusqu'à et giroud n'est qu'à 20 km heure
quand ça glisse ça me navre
j'ai mis 45 minutes à peu près la
conduisent de temps qu'en voiture
ouais t'es sérieux bouchons grand air
sur scooter et dillon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les gars même son scoot en effet des
télécoms un scooter